[Music]
4th of july celebrations are in full
swing and the summerlin area showed some
love for america with the annual
america's birthday party parade today
several members of our 8 news now team
also served as hosts
8 news now reporter victoria saha takes
a look
the july heat didn't stop summerlin
residents celebrating america's birthday
their annual america's birthday party
made a comeback after having to go
virtual last year i have never missed a
parade
long time residents like kathy koch
aren't alone
faith gregory has been coming to the
parade ever since it started
i love america i am such a patriot
and i have grown up in summerlin this is
actually my
16th year of the summerlin parade and
her love for the parade was
evident in her outfit and her hair she
got blue highlights just for the
occasion
so i just wanted to celebrate america's
birthday
support all of our military all of our
everything that america stands for
freedom independence and share of great
birthday
this year's parade had a shorter route
but a huge turnout
however small it is whatever it is i
know i'm going to love it
which surprised organizers didn't really
have an expectation we just wanted to
provide an event that we were very proud
of and that we thought
the community would enjoy pearl says the
parade almost didn't happen because of
the ongoing pandemic
but as soon as restrictions lifted on
june 1st he said they took action to
bring back a summerlin tradition
organizers say that they were just happy
that they were able to pull off this
parade in such a short notice
reporting from summerlin victoria saha 8
news now